[Music]
just like the long-awaited jetpacks and
hoverboards of tomorrow smart contact
lenses have been a long time coming
however a new way of putting electronics
into a contact lens is one step closer
to making contacts that can collect
information and display it researchers
have created a contact lens that
monitors glucose levels in tiers and
signals via LED light this could help
diabetics do away with painful daily
blood tests in the past contact lenses
integrated with electronics or stiff and
potentially harmful to the sensitive
human eye here the components are all
flexible and for the most part
transparent the graphene glucose sensor
the antennae and the LED are all
embedded in a silicon hybrid substrate
it sits on top of a breathable contact
lens the lens can stretch up to 30% it
is around 90 percent transparent the
lens is powered wirelessly through an
antenna and circles the pupil preventing
obstruction of sight with glucose levels
in the wearer rise to a predetermined
amount the LED pixel turns off though
this is a good proof-of-concept there's
still a ways to go these lenses haven't
been tested in people and there isn't a
practical way to power them but with a
few improvements we could be seeing a
lot more with our eyes
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]